LET'S GET THE PERSPECTIVE OF THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT ON THIS
VISIT.
MR. AMBASSADOR, GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR TIME AT THIS IMPORTANT
MOMENT.
CHINA SAID DON'T GO, SHE IS
THERE NOW.
THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE SAYS THIS
SHOULD NOT BE A BIG DEAL.
WHY?
WHY IS THE FOREIGN MINISTRY OF
CHINA SAYS THIS, IT WILL
DEFINITELY TAKE ALL NECESSARY
MEASURES TO SAFEGUARD TO
INTEGRITY IN RESPONSE TO THE
U.S. SPEAKER'S VISIT.
THEY SAID THERE WILL BE
OVERNIGHT MILITARY EXERCISES.
IT'S THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE
SAYING CHINA IS MAKING THIS A
BIG DEAL.
WHY?
>> FIRSTLY, SPEAKER PELOSI'S
VISIT TO CHINA IS REGION.
THE CHINESE SIDE HAS AFFIRMED
IT'S STRONG OPPOSITION AT
VARIOUS LEVELS THROUGH DIFFERENT
CHANNELS.
THE SPEAKER'S VISIT IS A MAJOR
VISIT UPGRADING THE TENSIONS
BETWEEN THEM.
IT IS A SERIOUS VIOLATION OF THE
ONE CHINA PRINCIPAL AND THE
PROVISIONS IN THE THREE U.S.
DRONE COMMUNICATES.
>> SHE WAS --
>> IT WAS A FOUNDATION --
>> I DON'T WANT TO --
>> SERIOUS INFRINGEMENT ON THIS
GOVERNMENT AND THE INTEGRITY.
>> SIR, LET ME JUMP IN FOR ONE
SECOND.
THAT IS THE POSITION OF YOUR
GOVERNMENT.
BUT SHE SAYS SHE IS THERE IN
HONOR OF THE TAIWAN
RELATIONSHIP.
I UNDERSTAND HOW DIFFICULT THIS
IS, BUT SPEAKER PELOSI SAYS IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT AT THIS TIME IN
THE WORLD FOR HER AS THE NUMBER
THREE PERSON IN THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT TO SHOW ITS SUPPORT.
CHINA COULD HAVE JUST SAID, LET
IT GO, PLAYED IT DOWN, IGNORED
IT, INSTEAD THE WHITE HOUSE
WOULD SAY IT IS CHINA LOOKING
FOR A PROVOCATION HERE.
>> WELL, TAIWAN IS NOT ABOUT
DEMOCRACY.
IT'S ABOUT CHINA'S NATIONAL
SOVEREIGNTY AND THE TERRITORIAL
INTEGRITY.
AND IT IS THE ASPIRATION OF THE
MORE THAN 1.4 BILLION CHINESE
PEOPLE TO ACHIEVE THE
REUNIFICATION OF CHINA, AND IT
IS ON PENDING WHEEL OF THE WHOLE
CHINESE NATION TO DEFEND OUR
NATIONAL SOVEREIGNTY AND
TERRITORIAL INTEGRITY.
NANCY PELOSI IS NOT A PERSON IN
STRAIGHT.
AS YOU MENTIONED, AS A SPEAKER,
NUMBER THREE IN THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT.
SO HER VISIT IN WHATEVER FORM,
AT WHATEVER TIME, CARRIES HIGH
POLITICAL SENSITIVITIES, AND IT
WILL RESULT IN THE ESCALATION OF
THE TENSION ACROSS TAIWAN STRAIT
AND ESCALATION OF THE TENSION IN
THE U.S./CHINA RELATIONS.
SO WE FIRMLY AND STRONGLY
CONDEMN AND PROTEST AGAINST IT.
AND YOU MENTIONED THAT THIS IS
NOT THE FIRST TIME OF THE
SPEAKER'S VISIT TO CHINA TO
TAIWAN.
LET ME SAY THIS.
25 YEARS AGO, WHEN THE SPEAKER
VISITED TAIWAN, IT WAS
COMPLETELY WRONG.
THE CHINESE SIDE WAS AFFIRMLY
OPPOSED TO IT FROM THE START.
THE U.S. SHOULD HAVE LEARNED
LESSONS FROM IT INSTEAD OF
REPEATING THE MISTAKE.
AND THE ONE MISTAKE CANNOT
JUSTIFY THE FOLLOWING MISTAKE IN
THE SAME NATURE.
>> SPEAKER EMPLOYEE SAY SAYS YOU
HAVE TO LOOK AROUND THE WORLD,
AND SHE SEES CHINA VIOLATING ITS
AGREEMENT WITH HONG KONG ABOUT
THE ONE GOVERNMENT, TWO SYSTEMS,
AND IT'S EXTRA IMPORTANT FOR THE
UNITED STATES TO MAKE PUBLICLY
CLEAR IT STANDS WITH TAIWAN.
YOUR GOVERNMENT OBJECTS.
IT JUST CONDEMNS IT.
WHAT WILL IT DO ABOUT IT IS THE
BIG QUESTION?
ARE THESE MILITARY EXERCISES TO
FRIGHTEN TAIWAN?
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IN THE
U.S./CHINESE RELATIONSHIP?
>> WELL, PEOPLE SHOULD NOT
CONFUSE THE QUESTION OF TAIWAN
WITH THE UKRAINIAN CONFLICT.
ON THE QUESTION OF TAIWAN, IT'S
CONCERNED CHINA's INTEREST, AND
SOME PEOPLE IN THE UNITED
STATES, THE ISSUE OF UKRAINE,
THEY EMPHASIZED NATIONAL
SOVEREIGNTY AND INTEGRITY.
BUT WHY?
THEY DO WHATEVER THEY WANT TO
DAMAGE CHINA'S COINTEREST,
INFRINGE CHINA'S NATIONAL
SOVEREIGNTY TERRITORY INTEGRITY.
THIS IS A PLAY OF DOUBLE
STANDARDS, SO WE FIRMLY REJECT
THAT, AND CHINA HAS EVERY RIGHT
TO DEFEND ITS SOVEREIGNTY AND
TERRITORIAL INTEGRITY.
WE ARE FULLY JUSTIFIED TO DO
WHAT WE MUST.
THE CURRENT SITUATION IS CREATED
PURELY BY THE U.S. SIDE.
SO OF COURSE IT HAS TO BEAR THE
RESPONSIBILITIES.
>> PEOPLE CAN HAVE DIFFERENT
OPINIONS ABOUT WHO'S RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE MOMENT.
WE ARE AT THIS MOMENT.
AND AS WILL RIPLY SAYS, THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT HAS ANNOUNCED
THESE MILITARY EXERCISES.
THE IS THE GOVERNMENT OF CHINA
SO DETERMINED TO GET TAIWAN THAT
IF NECESSARY, HE WILL TAKE IT BY
FORCE?
>> WELL, TO ACHIEVE A
REUNIFICATION, AS I SAID
EARLIER, IS THE FIRM AND THE
STRONG VIEW OF THE WHOLE CHINESE
NATION.
SO CHINA'S SOVEREIGNTY CANNOT BE
INFRINGED AND CHINESE PEOPLE
CANNOT BE HUMILIATED, AND THE
REUNIFICATION OF CHINA CANNOT BE
STOPPED.
WE SAID REPEATEDLY IN RECENT
TIMES THAT THE POA WILL NOT STAY
IDLE, AND THE BEAUTY OF THE
CHINA'S MILITARY IS TO DEFINE
THE CHINA'S SOVEREIGNTY
TERRITORY INTEGRITY.
SO WE WILL TAKE WHATEVER WE CAN
TO RESPOND AND TO PROTECT, TO
SAFEGUARD OUR SOFRTY TERRITORY
INTEGRITY, AND OUR RESPONSE WILL
BE VERY FIRM, STRONG, AND
FORCEFUL.
>> FULL, STRONG, AND FORCEFUL.
THOSE ARE POWERFUL WORDS.
I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME TODAY,
AND I HOPE YOU CAN STAY WITH US.
THERE'S A DISAGREEMENT ABOUT
SOME THINGS, BUT I APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> THANK YOU, SIR.
JOINING OUR CONVERSATION NOW,
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE WOOD
ROW WILSON'S CENTER AND THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE.
LET ME START WITH YOU FIRST, YOU
HEARD THE AMBASSADOR AT THE END,
VERY FORCEFUL LANGUAGE.
THE QUESTION IS WILL THE
GOVERNMENT IN BEIJING BACK UP
STRONG WORDS WITH STRONG
ACTIONS?
>> WELL, WE'RE ALREADY SEEING
SOME ACTION BEFORE SPEAKER
PELOSI'S ARRIVAL.
THE PRESIDENT'S OFFICE OF TAIWAN
CAME UNDER CYBERATTACK, AND IT
BECAME DYSFUNCTIONAL FOR ABOUT
20 MINUTES.
WE'RE ALREADY SEEING THIS LINEUP
OF MILITARY AGGRESSION AND
PROVOCATION BY THE CHINESE
ALREADY.
I THINK THE BEST CASE SCENARIO
TO CONCLUDE SPEAKER PELOSI'S
VISIT TO TAIWAN WILL BE THIS IS
AS BAD AS IT GETS.
BUT WITH THE BIG CHALLENGE IS
GOING TO BE WHAT IS GOING TO BE
TAIWAN'S POSITION IN THE LONGER
TERM.
WILL CHINA CONTINUE TO PRESSURE
TAIWAN AND WHAT WILL THE UNITED
STATES DO TO ENSURE THAT TAIWAN
CAN ACTUALLY WITHSTAND THE
LONGER TERM COERCION THAT CHINA
IS EXPECTED TO DO.
>> SO ONE OF THE QUESTIONS,
BETH, ON THE TABLE IS WHAT NOW,
THE WHITE HOUSE INITIALLY
OPPOSED THIS TRIP BY THE
SPEAKER.
ONCE IT WAS CLEAR SHE WAS GOING,
THEY DECIDED TO SUPPORT HER.
THIS IS JAKE SULLIVAN, AND
YOU'RE WATCHING THE PICTURES ON
THE STAGE.
SHE'S MAKING A VERY STRONG
STATEMENT HERE.
SHE'S BEEN ON THIS ISSUE FOR
30-PLUS YEAR IN TERMS OF THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT AND ITS
ABUSES.
JAKE SULLIVAN SAYS HE'S WORRIED
NOW THE CHINESE ARE GOING TO USE
THIS EXCUSE AS A PRETEXT.
>> A SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE HAS
TRAVELED TO TAIWAN BEFORE, AND
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS TRAVEL THERE
ALL THE TIME, INCLUDING SEVERAL
WHO HAVE ALREADY TRAVELED THERE
THIS YEAR, SO FOR CHINA TO TRY
TO TURN WHAT IS IN THE
HISTORICAL NORM INTO A CRISIS OR
TRY TO USE IT AS A PRETEXT FOR
AGGRESSION AAROUND TAIWAN,
THAT'S ON THEM, AND THEY WOULD
BE THE ONE ESCALATING.
>> IS THERE A RISK OF A SERIOUS
MILITARY ESCALATION IN AND
AROUND TAIWAN RIGHT NOW?
>> THERE IS SOME.
CERTAINLY WITHIN THE NEXT 24-48
HOURS, THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT
RISK BECAUSE WE ARE GOING TO SEE
SOME MILITARY ACTION.
THE EXERCISES ARE STARTING, AND
THE LAST TIME WE HAD A
HIGH-LEVEL VISIT WAS IN 2020,
AND THAT WAS THE UNDERSECRETARY
OF STATE FOR ECON.
WHEN HE WENT, THE CHINESE FLEW
ALMOST 40 PLANES ACROSS THE
ISLAND AND MAINLAND.
THAT WAS THE FIRST TIME THAT
HAPPENED.
IN THE '95-96 CRISIS, WE SAW
MISSILES FIRED NEAR TAIWAN.
I EXPECT WE'LL SEE THINGS LIKE
THAT HAPPEN, AND WE'RE GOING TO
SEE THE TAIWAN AIR FORCE
SCRAMBLE.
AND MARK MILLEY, THE CHAIRMAN OF
THE JOINT CHIEF OF STAFF JUST
WARNED ABOUT THEIR UNSAFE
BEHAVIOR.
I THINK THERE'S A RISK OF THAT,
AND CHINA IS GOING TO THREAD THE
NEEDLE.
XI HAS A LOT ON HIS PLACE AT
HOME AND DOESN'T NEED A CRISIS
RIGHT NOW.